guten morgen
und zwar heute machen den bau update
ohne die sally und zwar wir machen bauer
update aus dem realen leben bis er
wirklich ist also ich bin selber auf dem
bau groß geworden und ich lieb den bau
wenn man sieht immer am abend was man
noch hergestellt hat was man gemacht hat
und handwerker sind was richtig richtig
cool ist und das handwerk etwas richtig
cooles und bei meiner 1000 anders ist
beamten sie ist lehrerin so die hat nur
morgens und kuchen gebacken und ist dann
morgens zur arbeit mit dem kuchen haben
sie im lehrerzimmer was gegessen und und
und war glücklich wenn es zur arbeit
gegangen ist weil handwerker etwas
anderes bei uns geht es jeden tag um
leben und tod das heißt leben und tod
heißt wir wird zerreißen uns hier wie
wir es ist immer gefährlich und es ist
nicht immer sicher ob man am abend
wieder nach hause kommt und deswegen
möchte ich euch mal was ganz anderes
zeigen das leben auf einer baustelle und
mit handwerkern und die handwerker die
ich jetzt hier die nach alle sehen wäre
das seltene exemplar der handwerker
das sind alles meine freunde muss ich
ehrlich sagen das sind wir haben uns die
handwerker nicht danach aussieht haben
billigsten war sondern wir kannten die
ganzen handwerker schon die kommen alle
aus der region
das sind ganz ganz tolle menschen sind
unsere freunde ich habe auf dem bau
jetzt ja schon seit einem jahr andauert
habe ich ein paar freunde verloren weil
man sich einfach immer gekommen sind
aber wie gesagt ganz ganz tolle
handwerker haben wir und die zeige ich
euch jetzt also es gibt mal rein und ich
zeige euch mal das reale leben auf dem
handwerk auf dem bau
[Musik]
und so sitzt gerade aus es ist wirklich
8 uhr sind alle pünktlich auf der
baustelle
ich würde euch mal gern ein paar leute
vorstellen und es war dieser junge hat
er mit dem ball der so aussieht wie
pater abraham dass sich das schauspiel
das sich künstler und ein freund von uns
der ist auch der nachbar punch sally's
eltern bei uns in der türkei und kommt
aus balingen
das problem beim chance ist er schwätzt
halt nur schwerlich versteht keiner
schaut euch an was er gerade macht und
versucht zu erklären
dann haben wir drüben dallas der last
der ist zimmermann warst du bist immer
man geld
erst dachdecker genau das ist dachdecker
aber er ist momentan nicht auf dem dach
er ist im zimmer also ist erzählt sodann
der junge herr auf dem auf dem auf dem
gerüchte maximilian unter anderem ist am
von maximilian mit dabei sind
es ist immer so wenn auf dem balkon
kommen die italiener und die italiener
darf ich euch vorstellen
das ist roberto roberto werder ist ein
freund von mir der spielt italienische
banken mir kann kein fußball spielen
aber er hat das größte und beste
fliesenleger geschäft hier in der region
genau unter roberto macht alles umsonst
für mich wenn ein freund von mir ist
steht zé roberto auch gerne mal hat noch
eine rechnung gestellt ich hab die
nächsten drei tage nicht geschlafen aber
perfekte arbeit
dafür habe ich gut geschlafen die sind
alle bescheuert sein dass wir noch mal
mit drei jahren der eine sieht nichts
andere hört nix unser antrieb macht nix
und machen alle tun sie nix also war es
mein traum also immer das ist unser
unseren fensterbank und wir haben wir
sind ungefähr 20 leute und haben drei
tassen dh wir haben drei tassen für alle
wir haben auch keine löffel und das ist
auch der grund warum auf ihre frage
immer wo epidemien ausbrechen epidemien
brechen aus auf baustellen so und hier
ist ein beispiel
oder kaffeemaschinen beim kaffee habe
zwar seit jahrzehnten handeln gewinn 3
ein weiter so dass auf seiner vorstellt
keinen kaffee und keine getränke gibt
eine handvoll songs die schon mal
traurig ja gesagt nun könnte man gucken
dass wir auf jeden fall mal einen kaffee
und bezahl staaten billigen kaffee holen
jungs kann irgendwann billigen kaffee
holen aus dem haus der mutter ich mal
geklaut deswegen asche teurer hole dann
könnte man eine kiste cola holen das was
zu trinken hat ja und mir essen seit
drei jungen männer und frauen geschickt
oktober aber hat das gesehen neben 99
cent die konzerne steht ein zwei euro 99
red bull also studierende greifen ganz
gereicht so wie eben dieses thema hier
weil es ist ein entweder systeme und ich
werde jetzt einfach gehen und willigen
kaffee und williges chili con carne für
die männer holen alles darf bis gleich
[Musik]
schauen sie ganz kurz ich muss was
zeigen und zwar ihr wisst doch oftmals
im leben seither in der schule hat
matheunterricht und fragt euch warum
werde ich diesmal spät in meinem leben
oder wann werdet ist mein leben später
brauchen matte da darf ich kurz das
stift haben und zwar ist ganz einfach
auch ihr braucht alles was in mathe land
braucht ihr mal später in meinem leben
und zwar schon hat die richtige gleiche
gemacht 4x gleich hart 35 x b und
meistens ich bin ihr müsst dann die
hypothek news nehmen die an karte und
gegen krieg und es gibt dann immer zwölf
richtig richtig diesen wahnsinn
geschichte die seite merkt eigentlich
alles was in der schule land braucht ihr
später mal auf dem bau ist es ganz ganz
ehrlich alles gelernt das spiel war auf
der ringschule pub an der schule war
schon tagsüber abwasser schule ja ich
war heute führen fachhochschule genau
auf jeden fall lust leben mitgenommen
das komische entweder hat mein lehrer
und interesse damals irgendwas
gewechselt es passt was ich rechne
genau jetzt müsst ihr auf dem bau immer
mit einer recht und so haben wir wieder
was fürs leben gelernt wieder auf dem
bau
also allgemein dieser raum hier
wie soll ich sagen ich sage ich jetzt
mal eine schauküche hier drehen wir
unsere videos die ganzen videos von der
sally und deswegen machen wir diesen
raum etwas ganz ganz besonderes und zwar
so einfach so und so müssen industries
teils ein bisschen künstlich und
irgendwie einfach shabby chic irgendwie
sie alles mit drin
hier wird nach der küchen fries und zwar
ihr habt ihr in sichtbeton estrichboden
zeige euch mal ganz kurz hier an der
ecke zur auf der ces das ist ein
sichtbeton estrichboden bisher freien
freund bernd aus hockenheim gemacht und
der ganze boden hier ist haben wir viel
raum geschoben wird die kameras da
stehen deswegen haben sich bildung erst
geboren gemacht und dann hier ist so ein
tierchen fries küchen fries einfach die
hammer edelstahl eingehen eingelassen
ich habe mir edelstahl eingelassen und
hier kommen nachher diese wieder fließen
ihr seht ihr hier
wie kommen diese wiesen rhein dessen so
nicht fließend sorry mia platten kommen
diese via platten rhein gesehen so
richtig dick aus sie sind alle
handgemacht und ich liebe einfach diese
in diesem orientalischen stil das ist
richtig toll aus und da wo jetzt diese
diese schattierung sie kommt nachher die
küchen insel hin und hier haben wir
schon nach gut drauf gemacht wie gesagt
da der maximilian kommt morgen legt die
fließende robert ist morgen da und
werden fließen gelegt und am mittwoch
kommt eigentlich auch schon die küche
von claudia ist die zweite kirche als ja
vorliegt vor die kirche von der mama
gesehen das ist die zweite kirche nur
zum drehen und an die decken oben da
hängt mir die ganzen kameras sind da
haben wir das gleiche problem nicht mehr
was sie zu hause hatten dass die kameras
und schieben mussten dass sie auf
stativen gestand sind das die kids
gekommen sind
im ellbogen daran dass die kamera
haben ja dann wie gesagt ist es ja auch
ganz wichtig die wandgestaltung ihr seht
mal hier diese diese ecken und zwar gebe
es manchmal zuschauer sie macht das
schauspiel macht für die wandgestaltung
und zwar zur sichtung ist ich habe die
sendung letztlich haben sieht richtig
toll aus und da das schiff unter roberto
die machen jetzt stromverbrauch ist
zeigen euch mal ganz was es ist
das ist stufe von p und es gibt da diese
sich beton estrich von hähnchenfleisch
aus der staffel da ist
da gibt es eine tolle geschichten hat er
toll war die geschichte nicht da es im
lokal ausgebrochen und hat die ganze
stadt unter dem vulkanstaub begraben
und wir müssen mal eingeben pompeji in
italien ist keine lustige geschichte
auch eine schöne geschichte aber warum
weil hier ist mit dem vulkan asche mit
wenn robert und richtig dass vulkanasche
mit vulkangestein vulkangestein das
gleiche
und wie gesagt da tut da wirklich feld
von feld zu feld dessen auftragen und es
gibt nachher diese diese industrie optik
diese diese sichtbeton optik und da kann
nur von feld zu feld machen wir das ding
sie schnell trocknet
genau und merkt euch immer eins wenn
zwei handwerker einer meinung ist sind
ist einer kein handwerker so wer ist
hier kein handwerker ich tipp auf ok so
auch wir müssen dorthin schauen jetzt
nicht stören
jetzt sagt er gleich wir gehen auf den
sarg wahrscheinlich alles okay ich kann
euch das gesagt
[Musik]
wenn jetzt überlegen was er schon in
rechnung stellten schneller fertig ist
steht in keinem in keinem verhältnis an
ja wenn ich noch mal ein haus bauen
können um in der show nichts kann es
auch noch
[Musik]
wer jetzt ein paar meter weiter machen
jetzt richtig dass meine ja wenig bleibt
sitzen anwesen das ist schon mal ein
fensterplatz unsere schule heißen er war
bemüht bemüht reise genau dies bemüht ja
und er ist diese unter zug der jetzt
auch gerade wer wird noch hart und
draufgemacht der unterzogen nachher
aussehen wie ein verrosteter t träger
als er merkt richtig dass wir uns
richtig machen in der gemeinde der
wandgestaltung das ist richtig cool
aussieht als die sommersonne alte
industriehalle aussehen mit dem boden
mit dem sich beton estrich mit dem
träger und dann kommen hier über die
decke noch source oder so stahlmatten wo
dann muss oben rein gesetzt wird
also es ist wichtig wenn es nachher sehe
dass sie gigantisch aus dem markus
weiter in die anderen räume ich erkläre
ich habe ein bisschen was zu den anderen
räumen okay
so jetzt seid ihr gerade in der
werkstatt und herbergen der garage und
zwar aus dieser garage eine deckenhöhe
von 350 die wände sind schon verputzt
wieder schon sehen könnt und hier werden
nach unserer studios selbst videos
gedreht die selbe tier nachher ein
hochbeet machen
möbel bauen einfach alles auch für den
garten machen und es werden auch hier
filmen und ihr müsst euch so vorstellen
vielleicht die älteren unter euch kennt
vielleicht noch die sendung hör mal wer
da hämmert und hör mal wer da hämmert
das wenn man will hier in der garage
machen ähnlich haben am platz so in
unserer alten wohnung konnten wir das
meistens nicht da kommt ja kein staub
keinen lärm machen und hier könnt nicht
alles bauen und machen und euch nicht
anzeigen und hier an die wände
hier wird doch klinker gemacht das heißt
sie wird komplett alles rot verklinkerte
kommt eine coole werkstatt sein das
heißt es war immer mein traum der
eigenen werkstatt zu haben weil wir
haben das immer ein wohnung gelebt und
wir konnten wirklich nicht basteln nicht
passte so wie sally bastelt gerne und
einfach den garten machen und hier kann
man jemandem platz station und hier
damit ist alles machen was auch schon
drin ist das garagentor das ist letzte
woche gekommen und zwar es ist auch
natürlich made in germany von hörmann
und die haben das recht sein wenn sie
schneller alltag eingebaut es war
richtig genial und da oben ich hier
nochmal mehr sondern sollen sondern
nehme das an nicht oberlicht genau im
oberlicht hier oben dass wir ein
bisschen mehr licht hier drin haben was
ja auch in der garage passieren wird ist
folgendes und zwar werden wir hier schon
vorbereitung hatte ich ja schon mal
gesagt vorbereitung auf elektromobilität
das heißt wir haben noch keine
elektrofahrzeuge
wer aber vielleicht weil jedoch ein
bisschen teuer sind
erst ein paar jahren haben aber wenn man
jetzt schon mal die vorbereitung das wir
später mal nicht die wende auf reisen
müssen mit allem drum und dran
das heißt wir werden uns wirklich so
zwei super schade sein die später
irgendwann mal ein paar jahren ein
elektrofahrzeug leisten können dass wir
unsere fahrzeuge aufladen können weil
das ist die zukunft und das ist aber
jetzt schon gebaut berücksichtigen und
jetzt schon die ganzen leitungen dafür
lägen aber das wird jetzt hier schon
gemacht
diese kabel was ihr gerade sie dafür ist
der bruder von dalli dalli
verantwortlich der ist elektriker so was
wird ein elektriker in ein haus baut
natürlich verbauen ohne ende kabel
aber das ist richtig cool was wir hier
gemacht haben was er gedacht hat das ist
wirklich ein komplettes smartphone das
wird ein hammer haus das von uns lernt
und man hat ja heutzutage im angst vor
smart homes man sagt ja der da wusste er
hört mich ab denn frank hört mich ab
jeder hat angst vor smarthome holztage
aber dieses mal ist ganz ganz anders
mein haus meine daten das heißt unsere
daten bei uns wir müssen keine
internetverbindung haben gründen aber
eine haben und das haus lernt von uns
keine gimmicks also keine sachen wo
irgendwie sinnlos sondern will ich nur
ganz ganz sinnvolle sachen wo einem das
leben erleichtern
man sagt glaube ich habe mal gelesen
sind über 50.000 handgriffe pro jahr
weniger was du machen musst und das
macht das ist sein bruder der ist
elektromeister und er hat ihr seht ihr
volles rohr arbeit geleistet wir haben
komplett das bussystem wenn eine richtig
coole geschichte und das allgemein ist
der technikraum sie kommen die ganzen
schaltschränke rein die server auch für
die stürmer müssen wir überlegen und zu
hause ist nicht nur normales haus es ist
ja auch das unternehmen sallys welt ist
ja auch hier wo wir die videos
produzieren mit unseren freunden
zusammen wir haben ja inzwischen 20
freunden die mir zusammenarbeiten
das machen alle arbeiten außer ich mache
halt ihr denn dem bau jetzt mit den
jungs zusammen
und wie gesagt hier kommt technik ein
die ist der wahnsinn hier kommt zum
beispiel baby die anlage ein internes
anlage ein ganz tolles system ist zeigen
aber auch noch wenn wir so weit sind und
der raum ist schon komplett ausgefüllt
das ist ein riesen raubten kannst du mal
kurz kommt man hier noch ein bisschen
was
und das hat zum beispiel die firma gs
gemacht ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wahnsinnige arbeit geleistet und
wirklich immer immerzu punkte oder
termingerecht geliefert und wirklich
gigantische weil ihr seht auch das ist
richtig strukturiert aufgebaut richtig
toll und es ist wichtig dass es immer
sauber ist immer strukturiert ist und
das kannst du nur mit tollen handwerkern
mit tollen unternehmen und da haben wir
mit gott sei dank größtenteils ich würde
sagen zu 95% glück gehabt und jetzt
gehen wir von der garage ist stelle mal
vor ich war jetzt einkaufen habe jetzt
getränkekisten gewollt oder irgendwas
ist immer so bei den amerikanern ist
zeigt natürlich ein tolles system und
zwar ist es ist man auch schon 1 gegen
deutschland
du kommst direkt vom einkaufen verein
und kannst dann direkt die einkaufstüten
nehmen oder was du gesagt hast und
content direkt im vorratsraum das war
hier
was sie hier sehen ist ja ist der
vorratsraum ist ein bisschen lauten
lüfter und im vorratsraum macht
organisations videos wie man ihn sich so
ein haushalt das dass sich kurze wege
habe das alles etwas schneller geben
organisation ist wirklich alles auch bei
dass sally und das tolle an der ganzen
geschichte ist hier können wir die
ganzen tollen videos training haben eine
platz wird in sachen selber basteln und
ist es toll und direkt vom vom
vorratsraum brauchst freilich in den
wohnraum
das
mich noch
die höheren heizlüfter weil ich wurde
gerade das die ganze menge
schnellstmöglich trocknen und ist unsere
bewahrte die unsere privaten ich auch
nicht mehr auf filmen wenn er vor der
veranstaltung sind hier
als audio design hier anders und hier
haben nach einer disco und simon
wenn ja ein bisschen rum schauen jetzt
erstmals auch ist auf der baustelle mit
den handwerkern arbeiten es ist mir ganz
wichtig dass dein arbeitsplatz sauber
ist das ist immer wenn man arbeite
den schwierigsten handwerker in dem es
auch sauberen arbeitsplatz
das heißt nicht nur sauber arbeitende
ganze arbeit das muss sauber sein und
beendest aufputz die kommen jetzt
und wie gesagt hier treten das fenster
zu einem halben jahr gesagt dass er im
letzten video schon gesagt da war
richtig probleme gehabt
da habe ich aus falsche pferd gesetzt
muss ich ehrlich sagen
jetzt kommt der nächsten ein zwei wochen
kommentiert fußbodenheizung wieder
dieser sendung ist jetzt nur bei den
schwiegereltern oben und zwar die
schwiegereltern haben aufzug und jetzt
schreiben jetzt sagen wahrscheinlich mal
cool läuft bei den german aufzug stimmt
absolute aber selbst noch von der
anderen seite die schwiegereltern unsere
schwiegereltern die sind 70 jahre alt
die haben knieprobleme und man muss auch
jetzt schon über baut schon überlegen
was passiert wenn immer etwas ist was
ich in 20 30 jahren
wenn wir älter sind und da ist dieses
wie soll ich sagen dass das
altersgerechte bauen ganz ganz wichtig
und deswegen haben wir das für eltern
gemacht weil sie probleme haben wenn sie
schleppen müssen das den aufzug von
unten ist nur ein stück werden dass sie
einen aufzug haben und dass sie bei uns
holen können ohne unsere schwiegereltern
werde das hier alles gar nicht möglich
also ich liebe meinen schwiegereltern
aber alles das fliegen lieber mensch die
spieler manchmal auch die haben uns ist
alles ermöglicht hier
und weil sie immer für uns da waren wir
haben auf urlaub verzichtet damit es auf
unsere kinder aufpassen können dort aber
war der jeden tag da hilft uns auf der
baustelle und unsere eltern ist alles
deswegen sagen wir uns für eltern bei
uns haben und jetzt ermöglichen dagegen
einfach das alles hier
damit sie bei uns sind und wir bauen
auch ganz anders und klara zahlen
natürlich auch mit bisher schon sonst
aber das altersgerechte bauen ganz ganz
ganz großes thema und wenn jemand kurz
in ihre wohnung rein und unten zeigen
was altersgerechtes bauen in diesem
baufortschritt ein kreis altersgerechtes
bauen heißt natürlich wenn sie später
man wohl schon haben sollten ich hoffe
dass es niemals zutrifft dass sie hier
rein können das heißt die türe so etwas
breiter man kann im rollstuhl ganzkörper
durchgehen die türen sind sonder maß und
deswegen habe das rein gemacht und
altersgerechtes bauen heißt ja nicht nur
dass die türen breiter sind sondern auch
und breiter gang dass mir hier
durchfahren kann und auch was ganz
wichtig ist beim altersgerechten bauens
badezimmer
so altersgerechtes bauen heißt nicht nur
breitere türen sondern auch das bad muss
altersgerecht sein es muss barrierefrei
sein und da wollte natürlich dass die
eltern bei der wahl weil er nicht so
wichtig haben
auch muss alles ebenerdig sein hier der
breite gang muss sein und es ist sowohl
für die eltern allplan muss wenn ich
komplett alters und behindertengerecht
sein wenn wir wissen selber nicht wenn
wir älter werden was machen wir dann in
meinem bauch
vorausschauend auf dem nächsten 30 jahre
und vielleicht irgendwann in dieser
wohnung oder silber vorkommen dass man
das damals gemacht haben und deswegen
machen wir es für die eltern weil es dir
doch mal rüber zu papa da ist nicht auf
gerade da ist schaut gerade tüchern
ja der farbe erstrahlen abgehauen
und hier sind weil meine schwiegereltern
und zwar wird gerade ihre küche
aufgebaut
die queens auf nur freunde sind immer
kühl studio in kandel das ist die
claudia frey und normalerweise in seine
küche plant die whiskys office man nimmt
sie eine stunde zeit für zweimal plante
klicken
aber die claudia dass sie wirklich einen
ganzen tag für diese tür die zeit
genommen für uns und wenn uns der küche
aufgebaut und da sie auch in der region
ist wie gesagt wir setzen ganz verstärkt
auf regionale partner auf handwerker
macht das auch brauche es ist immer
besser und es ist roberto werde jetzt am
wochenende die fliesen gelegt am samstag
am wochenende fließen gelegt am samstag
da war jetzt richtig genial dessen via
fließen kommen auch aus bacharach
das ist auch in freie 50 die armut lager
richtig genial und robert hat es echt
cool gemacht wie sich toll wenn man mit
freunden arbeitet die lassen einen
möglichen mich im stich und arbeiten
wirklich samstags und sonntags teilweise
auch schwarz für mich der wahnsinn also
wirklich alle fließen technik hofstatt
bayer genial roberto geile sache
bewerten wird es auf jeden fall ihr seht
die kombination zwischen schwäbischen
türken und italiener kann funktionieren
und das ist eine küche die wird so vor
dem ist mama von der sally hat wirklich
noch nie in ihrem leben eine nagelneue
küche gehabt und jetzt hat zwischenlagen
neue kühler und es wird ein bisschen
landhausstil auch die geräte wo sie drin
haben also wir haben ja pyrolyse
dampfgarer funktion irgendwas und ich
mache haben ganz ganz normale geräte
habe niemand wirklich nur normale geräte
muss liegt ein und ausgeht aber sie
trotzdem cool kochen und backen kann und
wie gesagt und diese küche bauen die
jungs gerade auf die werbung für die
küche komplett den ganzen tag brauchen
und ich sage schon ganz schön weit und
später werden die wände noch tapeziert
und hier unten kommt noch ein holzboden
rainer kersten kommen auch ein tolles
produkt aus schweden ist auch ganz ganz
cool haben wir beim auch wenn freud für
uns der baumarkt hat kann man doch
gekauft wirklich genial wer oder was
meinst du das was hier wird
ja genau kommen wie es super rausgesucht
persönlich italiener haben ja geschmack
und aus meinem fußball und bei autos
funktioniert das programm zustimmen ja
nicht ganz also was design angeht ich
stelle eigentlich ganz vorne dabei aber
weil du es bist lassen was man durch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so jungs ich bestelle zu essen jeden
döner wer von euch ist veganer keiner ok
keiner veganer keiner zeuge jehova wir
wohl etwas zu essen gibt es wieder für
alle
[Musik]
das fand ich lustig gemeint also nicht
erfüllbar nicht schlecht aus das
erledigt jetzt was es lag an einer von
münchen mitgebracht zu einem kloß im
werbegeschäft von wände gestalten auch
von backwaren keine ahnung so auf jeden
fall wir haben jetzt in gold für die
ganze truppe und essen
wir wissen jetzt alle zusammen ist auch
cool sound zusammenhalt und mit den
jungs macht richtig spaß hört nicht auf
den ski du bist ja die heißt es nochmal
wenn die affen klettern
so sieht's aus auch immer man will ja
auch richtig toll gemacht ihr seht hier
haben verschieden
dieses rennen
als anhänger er ist jetzt alle zusammen
durch schlecht und desinfektionsmittel
stehen sie ganz wichtig hier auf der
baustelle definitions minute männer die
hähnchen sind wie
[Musik]
jetzt heißt es abwarten warum holen
warum kamera haben einen kameraden da
wird alles aufgenommen seien gezählt
dort legt man auf einmal einen tisch
gibt es brötchen gezählten was er zu
sehen so viel bewegung schau mal
schwimmer darüber wie die auf die dose
wochenlang wo entlang essen wir in dosen
foto lied runde durch das heu ist
kamerateam wer glaubt schon lange
nächste wahl seiner ausschüsse sucht in
bar wären wir es jetzt zusammen und dann
geht's wieder kräftig weiter läuft wir
müssen schnell essen also aufzubauen wir
müssen schon mehr weitermachen
das wird richtig cool danke übrigens
danke
so jetzt mitten auf der baustelle haben
gerade in besprechung mit dem alex mit
dem ski und leute mit eingefallen wäre
hier keine arbeitsgenehmigung hat
schwarz auf der baustelle ist vielleicht
unterhalt an seine ehefrau zahlen muss
bitte jetzt den raum verlassen
[Musik]
warst du auch die veranstalter auf der
baustelle
nachdem das geklärt ist also wir sehen
uns
[Musik]